boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation i'm your host alan sakhyan we
are on site in los angeles in california
i'm really excited to be talking about
all things related to skepticism all
things related to science all things
related to humanism to biases into how
to best move forward and prosper
collectively we have dr michael schermer
joining us on the show not a simulation
that's a real flesh that's the real
question but i have not uploaded my body
and brain into the cloud yet yes is the
key there yet
and
for those that don't know michael's
background he's the founder of the
skeptic society which has 55 000 members
he's the editor-in-chief of its magazine
skeptic
he's a 214-time monthly columnist for
scientific american from 2001 until
january 2019
and he's a presidential fellow at
chapman university where he teaches
skepticism 101
he helped found and run this is an
interesting fact the 3 000 mile
trans-continental bicycle race across
america and he did 3 000 feet of
elevation just today and how many miles
40. yeah 47 miles 3 hours 47 miles i'm a
little slower than i used to be but
it's a great way to stay healthy i can't
believe you have so much cycling
experience he's a 15 times author as
well with new york times bestsellers why
people believe in weird things the
believing brain why darwin matters the
science of good and evil the moral arc
and have most recently heavens on earth
i'm really excited to dive into deb
thank you for having us you're welcome
super pumped
i really think that your work is so
crucial
we are
find ourselves as stewards of earth now
over a period of a long time and
now more than ever it's important to
realize how we've collectively learned
as a society and how we've built this up
and we've taught children we've built up
this collective knowledge
yet
the last 500 years specifically have
been so crucial due to the scientific
revolution and us being able to really
layer up this objective truth
and i want you to speak about the
synthesis of what has happened over
these last 500 years in the big history
perspective and where we're at now with
that current state of humanity because
as you write in the moral arc
we
are
it's arcing in the long term towards a
more just
world i think so and another way to come
at this this may be my next book maybe
uh of governing mars i'm thinking about
calling it governing mars i mean we're
about to colonize mars and no one's
talking about well what kind of
government we're going to have there
what kind of rules and laws and economic
systems who who owns the oxygen that's
produced and the water i mean it's this
is not like europeans coming to america
where there's free air free water free
food and
uh you know we're gonna it's gonna be
quite the challenge and in a way
the way to think about that is well what
have we done here
on earth that worked and what didn't
work and what works better than than
something else or shades of spectrum of
success or lack of success of governance
and economics and all that stuff
and that's what the moral arc is about
is you know well
well things have clearly gotten better
um and you know unless you just want to
deny all the progress that's happened
over the centuries like the abolition of
slavery and the slave trade and capital
punishment and torture and the expansion
of civil rights and civil liberties and
women's rights and gay rights and now
animal rights and who knows robot rights
might be next
um you know that we've made a lot of
progress and you know poverty will be
ended by 2030 is the u.n projection
uh that's not to say that everybody's
going to be wealthy but
not being impoverished is a huge huge
improvement
i mean who cares about global warming if
you don't have three square meals a day
to eat right so to get people to care
about curating the earth
into the future in a stable sustainable
way
you got to have
food and shelter in the basics of life
so
that's kind of what i've been thinking
about the last few years and going
forward
uh is i think this is probably the most
important thing we could do
whether we go to mars or not is sort of
secondary to we should think about what
we're going to do if we go there because
then that'll
focus back on well what have we been
doing here maybe we should do more of
that like if i was
in venezuela if i took over venezuela
now we're talking on the day that
there's a huge meltdown there
you know what would i do you know if i
did if i wasn't going to be the typical
dictator and just stay in power for as
long as i possibly can by
corruption and bribery and assassination
or whatever that's what everybody
normally does when in failed states you
know maybe i'd look to the u.s
constitution or the british constitution
or the french constitution or whatever
and go okay let's take the parts that
work that we like we don't like that tax
system we like this one we like these
kinds of bills of rights but not those
or whatever and and and leave a legacy
of
and why are we doing that because it
worked over here let's try it here
so i think that's the best thing and we
and that really is science because it's
an experiment
you know
people don't think of like political
science as a science
or economics as the dismal science or
whatever no no don't think of like think
of it like an experiment that's run
with results so we have 50 different
states 50 different state constitutions
in the united states they all have
different tax systems different gun
control laws uh and so forth those are
experiments so let's look at the outcome
like okay these kinds of gun control
measures seem to work to reduce gun
violence these don't seem to work so
well so maybe we had to jettison those
and try those and
that's that's the scientific method
right there
this is exactly why i love you so much
michael because i have also spent a lot
of time thinking about how to properly
govern mars and yeah yeah
i got a lot of time on this and i'm
actually i'll interview you for my book
i also really want to press elon on some
of these questions and as well as the
next contenders because who
when we land there what are like you
said what are these best techniques of
civilizational
progress that we can bring to mars so we
don't have the same errors the same
hiccups what are the best constitutional
principles etc and
one of the things that are important to
press is how are we going to collaborate
are we going there as an earth as a
unity or are we going there as separate
nations or separate corporations and
we're gonna how are we gonna treat the
other colonies that get there when china
lands how will the u.s behave will we be
helping each other with rovers and with
water supplies etc yeah and etc so these
are very pressing thought experiments
simulations to run in our mind about
what is going to happen when we move
into uh uh interplanetary colonization
which we will absolutely be doing in the
next couple of decades i'm really happy
that have you read this book on
seasteading do you know about sea steady
yes c-setting is exciting this is i just
finished the book because i met the
author at a conference recently and
you know when i first heard about this
through peter thiel i thought oh this is
just insane no one's gonna do this but
really now that i see what's going on
these are experiments more experiments
yeah by all means let's do more of this
kind of stuff and see what happens
that's the best thing we can do because
the way science progresses is through
trial and error so karl popper famously
describes science at the scientific
method as conjecture and refutation so
you're conjecturing you're just
spitballing ideas you're
you're throwing stuff out maybe it's
this maybe it's that i don't know you
you come up with stuff you know
screenwriters do this for television
shows they'll sit in a room and just
throw out a hundred different ideas
maybe one or two or three are good the
rest are junk that's actually the way it
is in science
and uh you know people that are outside
of science you know they think you guys
are so close-minded you can't accept
radical new ideas because look this one
was right and this one was right it's
like dude you have no idea there were
like 10 000 ideas like that most of them
are just completely insane and they're
wrong so we have to be kind of
conservative
in what we end up embracing as the truth
with the small t because most ideas are
so the only way to do it is you know
open inquiry free
speech free inquiry open peer commentary
and criticism debate disputation
and from there it kind of winnows out
the stuff that's probably not such great
ideas and you end up with a handful that
are better yep
and there have actually been some hugely
missed opportunities i'll get to that in
a moment with with for that with
seasteading specifically the idea of
running these experiments of being able
to live in very
eco-friendly ocean
dwelling communities is very fascinating
and it's in international waters it
there's a lot of cool stuff going on
with trying these experiments out uh in
governance and in prosperity and then
the missed opportunities that i was just
speaking about earlier michael is a big
advocate for like you just mentioned
debate civil discourse on these ideas of
running these experiments and i think we
had some majorly missed opportunities
and we're continuing to miss them
because for example rather than google
having
james moore and the other
leading biologists sociologists
scientists
in a debate about the memo we right
there was none of that and so we're
missing that and same thing right now
with peter james helen and and
the
the foundation of scientific truth being
being we're showing how we can't
add errors to the foundation of
scientific truth and again this needs to
be on a national stage on an
international stage as a debate that's
how i wish we would do it
well it is done it just needs to be done
more and of all people to reject that
the left was always in support of
that very process so they've gone up the
deep end with this business of um
you know hate speeches violence and and
and that then expands you know mission
creep that expands to pretty much
anything i don't like including
somebody's theory about gender
differences and cognitive abilities or
whatever but if you go online and type
type in pink or comma debate about
gender
cognitive differences there's a debate i
forget the woman
another harvard scientist and they go at
it you know what about this study the
well this study well uh these findings
were disputed well why the methodology
so and they go back and forth back and
forth this is how it's done
and then you can judge yourself but this
idea that you know we're going to
squelch the speech of people we don't
like
big mistake big mistake agreed and
when you know you speaking with joe
rogan about this as well have made it
have you guys both made it clear that
there are some conspiracies which are
true and it's very important for us to
help
pile on the evidence make these
scientific hypotheses test them figure
out the truth embed that into history
and and adequately move
forward what you've been teaching about
scientific humanism has been very
interesting to me
to me i think a lot about how the
universe is like code and we can
understand it better with math and with
science
and these laws that govern our nature
and our and even us as humans that then
by understanding it we can build a
better foundation of civilization so
i want you to speak on the importance of
scientific humanism as we move forward
yeah i think
the humanist movement needs to
uh bifurcate a little bit or evolve or
something that you know it started
really in the early 20th century mostly
leftists and liberals
uh in a reaction to other political or
religious movements um but then you know
by the time i kind of got into it in the
80s it was very strongly uh affiliated
with a political movement and i'm trying
to steer it back toward a scientific
movement
because the problem with most such
activists or social groups is that they
they splinter you know there's this kind
of fusion fission so you fuse and grab
as many people as you can
are like-minded people here we go we
have a movement and then they start to
splinter apart in fission when there's
disagreements over ideological
differences and then that you see again
mission creep with that like you know uh
you know who's the real feminist or the
real humanist or the true atheist you
know are you uh
are you a militant atheist or are you
one of those milk toast atheists
practically an agnostic you know we
can't have you in our group you know
it's like you know dudes we have we are
few in number we have a you know tiny
little tent here and you want to kick
people out big mistake but that happens
happened to the marxists and the
socialists and the feminists happened to
the objectivists ayn rand's movement you
know when she died in 1982 um the famous
students was only like a dozen people at
her funeral and hardly anybody really
cared that that this legendary figure
had died
in terms of her following because she
had kicked everybody out as not being
pure feminine or pure objectivist enough
write down to which movies you want to
see what music you like to listen to
which cigarettes you smoked or whatever
all this is in the biographies of her
by people that were on the inside that
got kicked out for various sins right
this is a huge mistake and all social
movements make it so i don't want the
humanist movement to do that or the
atheist movement there was an atheist
plus movement the plus being social
justice
what is that i mean that sounds good i'm
in favor of social justice aren't you
well what what does that mean exactly
and then all of a sudden we're not
talking about science and reason and the
supernatural and the natural and all
that we're talking about abortion rights
or reproductive rights or or whatever
these are political issues which is fine
but
again we want a bigger tent what let's
just define ourselves by what we stand
for you know science and reason and open
inquiry and and so forth and then you
know people can differ they are going to
differ
you know my own family just you know
four or five of it we don't agree on
anything about what we do
i mean there's lots of disagreements
about stuff you know so you expand that
to a social movement to a state a nation
you have so the point of a good
governance system is that it's flexible
and open
to disagreements to move forward solve
problems that keep moving forward
it's a problem solving technology
that acknowledges that there's this
conjecturing refutation people are
spitballing ideas boom boom boom and
they're gonna differ
and that's just the way it's gonna be
it's always going to be that way
i feel like we must get out of the us
versus them mentality that this is an
earth this has just one
civilization on it of all plants animals
and humans and then
we
have to do our best to identify these
protocols these resource frameworks that
maximize flourishing and like you said
bring those to the next steps eradicate
malevolence identify and eradicate
malevolence how how we best do that
needs to go through a process of
discourse
and i'm i'm curious
you know you write about this
a lot in the moral arc
it's really important that people
embody the full realization that things
have gotten so much damn better
poverty
down diseases down
baseline of electricity food water
education health care up for everyone
around the world and we're bringing it
more and more to the developing places
faster faster they're leap frogging
they're
there are places in developing countries
that are not going through the landline
system yeah right they're going to just
skip that stage
perfect yeah absolutely um but we're we
really are fighting human nature i mean
you just saw this
we're taping this right on the heels of
this incident in washington dc with the
native american vietnam vet and the
young 16 year old catholic school boy
uh there
and initially it was just like a one
minute video clip
and everybody just jumped on this
uh you know like and took sides and and
you know just was outraged outraged on
you know social media
and uh to the point where like
kathy griffin said you know let's dox
these docks these little and
really just destroy them and the
comedian put the picture of that young
boy's face up there and said that this
is a the most punchable face i've ever
seen you know bam wearing that mega hat
and then you know like two days later
everybody's like oh i'm sorry i gotta i
made a huge mistake i didn't know that
there was another video more evidence
more evidence so
it's really hard
it's really hard to overcome that i mean
i feel it you know when i see something
online
instantly you just know the amygdala is
kicking in the fear response the anger
you know the tribalism and those are the
bad guys that we're the good guy it's
just so natural
uh but we have i don't know we just have
to combat it we just have to say put the
brakes on count to ten let's wait you
know and act like journalists
investigative journalists but even a lot
of journalists jumped on it the catholic
school of that boy they were going to
kick them all out
they didn't even wait to see if there
was
other evidence so that's what we're up
against i mean it's really scary
sometimes i feel
like we're just rats in a skinner box
and there's a russian bot you know
pushing the the shaping buttons like
give him a pellet give him a pellet give
him electric shock pellet electric shot
pellet
and i'm just like bouncing around
you know and that's what i thought of
with the whole russian hacking of the
election i mean the way it's discussed
it's like we're we're just uh tom
autonoma automata walking around
bouncing all like a pinball game you
know depending on who's pushing us it's
like what happened to human agency and
reason and and you know self-control and
all that we need to
develop those skills because they're
there
this ability to slow down and think
critically about a variety of sources
about a multivariate
way of perceiving things instead of a
unidimensional way of perceiving things
to desire nuance in all conversation
to look at someone else in the eyes and
realize their humanity have that
emotional intelligence as well
that these principles need to be baked
into
us adults and our children of the future
otherwise discourse will suffer
especially as we move into further into
the exponential technology echo chamber
biases
etc bots yep deep fakes
era
i'm worried about the deep fake thing
that that's really looking bad because
you can make anybody say anything and it
looks pretty close to real now
that's going to shake shape shake things
up a lot in terms of evidence what what
constitutes reliable evidence on a small
scale you know look there's bigfoot or
there's the aliens and
they look pretty good
uh you know we're gonna need more than
that now and that's gonna be the case
with
these kinds of incidences where there's
marchers or protesters and something
happens and what if somebody put
somebody's face on there and you don't
know
yeah or someone like myself that
comments publicly a lot on things i can
easily be made to say something i never
said
i got my twitter account hacked a couple
weeks ago um
deepak chopra's a friend so he always
sends me articles pretty much every
couple days he's sending me articles
most of them the ones that he wrote but
others just along the lines of what
supports his position okay so i get a
little tweet you know hey michael i got
this great article in which i talk about
you i'm like oh deepak mentioned me i
got to read this
so i'm you know it's early morning i'm
just kind of uh you know the bbc oh my
god deepak wrote something from the bbc
about me you know just give just just
type in your your twitter password and
open the article and i'm like okay
oh there's like five minutes later joe
rogan sam harris some of my other
friends going michael i think you were a
hack i'm like oh
oh so i contact deepak he goes yeah i
was hacked about an hour ago i'm like oh
how did i fall for this this is
unbelievable and i thought okay i better
do something about my account because
whoever this is probably going to post
stuff like you know
my account is saying something super
positive about richard spencer and the
neo-nazis or something you know nothing
like that happened i really have no idea
why this person did that other than just
for the fun of it but that's the world
we're heading in and you know i'm pretty
savvy about these sorts of things not to
get fooled by scams and cons and stuff
because it is what i do and yet boom i
just felt right for it you know i feel
like a complete idiot but there it is
and so
and the people i've interviewed about
this uh security internet security
experts
they tell me is you know everybody falls
for these not everybody but you know
it's pretty easy to fall for that
and i got lucky it didn't cost me
anything but i could see now
how easy it is to manipulate social
media
it's going to get worse probably i think
we need to grow up
we need to grow up our own morality
first our own
intelligence in critical thinking and
reasoning in conversation we need to we
need we need to start feeling like we
were saying earlier with emotional
intelligence as well
that sort of human-centric heart-centric
unity-centric perspective
will enable us to continue the moral arc
forward
through this mess of exponential
technology as well as through the the
good things that exponential technology
is going to bring
okay i think norms social norms
are a big factor it they're not lost
it's not top down it's bottom up
of just the way we talk to each other
the language we use what's acceptable or
unacceptable
the social media and the online
community it's still pretty early
and we don't have a lot of good norms
set up yet you know and all the social
media companies are scrambling to figure
out
how to
regulate their own
business before the government starts
doing it because it's it's going to
happen pretty soon
so what kind of norms do you set of
acceptable language you know we're
seeing people get kicked off of twitter
and facebook and instagram now because
they use the n-word say okay that's kind
of an obvious low-hanging fruit one but
what other things can i not call
somebody or use as an adjective because
that's going to expand
and uh you know when you see someone
like you know ben shapiro is an
anti-semites like what you know he's
jewish right i mean you just you know or
or this person or that person a is a
neo-nazi or nazi or it's like no they're
not i mean what are you insane that word
has no meaning anymore so i think if we
if we up the norms to say just stop
doing that you can't do that anymore
stop it either the person gets kicked
off or better just shamed or people
don't uh
retweet their or pass along their
articles or whatever
and that's i think how social and moral
change happens more than top-down laws
you need laws you can't discriminate you
can't slave people whatever
but it but you really want to change the
hearts and minds of people that happens
from the bottom up through norms what's
acceptable and not dawkins makes the
point that you can identify a novel
almost down to the decade when it was
written just by the language
at least in english of how the author
talks about women
and jews and blacks minorities any you
know just the way people are talk
described
and it's like wow you would never use
that language today that's right but
that was acceptable in 1920s and then it
started to shift by the 40s and kind of
see the language change that's where it
really happens yeah that's actually
being able to see the evolution of
ethics of the human ethics and we need
to be very careful as well as we move
forward to not be so outrageous to dig
back 10 years into people's histories
and just try and and shame them rather
than i'd rather than have a discourse
with them and see that oh they've
evolved past where they were 10 years
ago
oh the guy that was going to do the
academy awards what was his name uh
kevin hart kevin art yeah i mean i mean
how many times does poor guy have to
apologize before he's let back in i mean
so that's another worrisome thing the
point doesn't seem to be justice
and let's correct things in
error correction it seems to be we want
to destroy lives
that's really scary because once it
turns on
you may be into it yourself but once it
turns on you
and that's the fear you know once you
have the apparatus set up
that we can destroy the bad people's
lives
then then it'll expand to get you know
everybody else including you
that's very dangerous
you also identify that the rise of
democracy has been so critical for us
that that has also caused people to see
that voting is a is a sport that
everyone participates in and that
as we add new protocols
trust-based protocols moving forward it
can make it even easier for us to
participate in all helping make
decisions also that
the premise of of
everyone being treated equally and
having an equality of opportunity for
people to pursue whatever brings the
most meaning and actualization in life
is
really important that's one of the most
fundamental things that we care about
helping people understand and
incorporate into their lives and science
has been sort of
the best tool that we've had in the last
several hundred years to build up on
this foundation of maximizing prosperity
and now and in many ways it's having
issues with the foundation and we've
been targeting some of these issues
as we've been talking
and
really it's the science of morality that
speaks to how to maximize both an
individual's flourishing and the
collective's flourishing teach us a bit
more about that
yeah i think um
yeah going forward it says this is kind
of the big big picture question um
yeah
i do want to steal man the arguments on
the other side for a moment that is
uh like i i saw
a short clip from an interview martin
luther king gave
1967 which the interviewer was saying
well
why can't the blacks pull themselves up
by their bootstraps like the irish did
and the chinese did and the germans did
and the italians did and the poles did
and you see all those you know polish
american german-american
italian-american communities in new york
city they were little gangs essentially
but then they
you know it got inculcated the american
way and now we don't think of them as
hyphenated americans anymore they did it
the jews they were oppressed well how
come the blacks can't do it he made the
point well none of them were brought
here against their will and enslaved for
centuries and the jim crow laws and so
on and so forth that he was then
fighting
so i have to say that even though as a
kind of classical liberal libertarian i
tend not to like big government programs
to
uh pull people up because it's kind of
condescending to them like you can't
make it without our handout
and
those programs tend to grow and big and
then there's a lot of corruption and
abuse of the system i don't like that
but you know president johnson's point
you can't bring a man to the start line
of a rate i'm an athlete
and they've had no training at all they
had no practice they just put them on
there and say go you're free to compete
against all these other athletes that
are professionals and trained and had
all these opportunities that's not
actually fair so when we say we
definitely don't want
equality of outcome because that's that
that's a failed experiment but equality
of opportunity has a little bit of a
hitch that not everybody
uh has the same backgrounds
so i i do think you know we have a moral
obligation to help people train them get
them up to the starting line how that's
done you know through private uh
nonprofits or through government agents
you know that's a debatable point
education of the children into the world
yeah
jonathan height makes his point uh he
and
um greg lukianov in their book the
coddling of the american mind they have
an example of the
the us army in the 50s i think it was
decided we're going to integrate
the army now
and blacks will have all the
opportunities whites have
but they they were not doing as well the
integration system was not working why
because they were the blacks could
simply not compete
in the tasks that they had to do why
because they had
such crappy educations as children so
the army said okay we're gonna we're
gonna get them up to snuff here through
extra trading and work and sure enough
they did and then then then the
the the opportunities were open and much
more equal equality of opportunity was
really there
so that's a good example that it can be
done whether bottom up top down whatever
can be done
uh so i think we do
we have a ways to go in terms of the
moral arc we have a ways to go of that i
just wrote an article for colette on uh
the role of luck in how lives turn out
you know it's it's much bigger than you
think if you have to expand the idea
what you mean by luck so it's not just
you know i got lucky and i met you today
and through you i meet some producer and
next thing i know i have my own hit tv
show on nbc or something like that i
said boy that was luck but but but not
just that just that you know i was born
white
middle class my parents sent me well i
went to public schools but they were
nice public schools and
and my parents helped me out with my
college tuition
at pepperdine for example and
and and also my parents were
had a lot of energy and intelligence and
were hard working now they didn't go to
college at all but
but i inherited those characteristics
from them genetically and socially and
environmentally in the home
and so i got to thinking about that
because in terms of checking your
privilege well that i have to say that i
was pretty lucky in that sense because
when i see people that like poor black
kids born to a single mom in the ghetto
you know and say go out and make
yourself what you want it's america
yeah well this poor kid is probably not
even thinking of you know taking the
sats and then going to harvard and then
getting you know
this doesn't even enter their mind
because they don't have that cultural
background or those inherited
personality traits you know and so on
and the basic needs
yeah yeah so i think there's a lot there
we we should be empathetic to
those the liberal arguments there we
should still man those and acknowledge
yes those are actually really good
points
uh i think maybe you go too far in the
affirmative action
you know enough is enough now you know
now we're discriminating against asians
at harvard or whatever okay this isn't
right
uh but for sure the program you know
started with you know good intent
because that those things are true
about the different backgrounds
that's a really important point and
we're actually seeing
uh the largest
as we're hockey sticking in population
and capitalism is evolving we're seeing
more and more maximization of
shareholder values and then we're
realizing whoa whoa actually we need to
do a a new model of a moral corporation
one that does help shareholders but also
helps not only the employees of that
corporation but also
provides benefits to the rest of society
to want to help them raise that baseline
so this is that next evolution and we're
now seeing more and more people mark
benioff step forward and talk about
solving the inequality issues and
actually make progress there and then
gates and buffett and dalio have all
stepped forward and said we've benefited
greatly from this we want to help
address how to do a capitalism 2.0
what's our next step here and that's
very exciting yeah this is an example i
think of bottom-up
norm shifting rather than top-down say
taxing the rich that's such a kind of a
19th 20th century way of thinking of how
we can help people that need help well
just take the rich successful people and
just take as much of their money as you
can above you know a million a year 10
million a year whatever it is
how about we shift the norms such that
all billionaires want to give away at
least 50 percent of their money well
they've kind of done this themselves
they have this sort of club there's that
i think fortune the giving pledge yeah
the giving pledge uh
and
okay so if you're not a member of that
club you're like well i better i better
i want to get a member of that club look
how much attention they're getting and
recognition and that feels good
and well heck 5 million 5 billion is
going to be enough for me my kids i can
give the other 5 billion away something
like that so that actually is more
effective because when it's their money
someone like gates especially
uh you know he's a scientist
thinking about well what's the if what
can i get for every dollar you know in
terms of the the outcome like how many
lives am i saving through potable water
and vitamins and
vaccinations and mosquito nets and
things like that is unbelievably more
effective than just say you know tax the
rich and then we'll put it in the
government coffers and hope there's not
too much corruption
there well you know we know historically
what happens with that so
i like the new techniques better yeah
there's no better way to
evolve one's own
spiritual presence on the planet once
they reach that billionaire threshold
than to help other people
even when you only have
basic needs met it still
brings you so much pleasure light
happiness to help other people
okay i want to talk about how science's
mission is protopia this is very
interesting
how
incremental progress towards improvement
rather than perfection is this premise
that we want to build on and i want to
know how exactly we
do that because we just mentioned all
these you know billionaires yadda yadda
there's i believe 3 000 or so of them on
the planet 2 000 ish and so
do we enable the world leaders that are
currently at
davos in switzerland do we currently at
the world economic forum do we let them
guide the future of civilization do how
do we enable 7.7 billion people to
have a say in what happens on the planet
is that the best way yeah for sure and i
think i think the internet social media
all these
uh avenues that are opening up to
everybody you know it's just a matter of
years before everyone on the planet has
a cell phone
access to
wikipedia for example and pretty much
access to all human knowledge for free
instantly you know we're pretty getting
pretty close to that that's more
empowering than anything else you could
do
uh once you've particularly ended
poverty and where they can actually have
a cell phone three square meals a day a
roof over their head and so on those
basics
that people like gates are working on
how to give them a voice well democracy
is better than autocracy and theocracies
and so on what kind of democracy you
want you can play with that but
just the people having a voice
where there has to be checks and
balances against the corruption like in
venezuela now um but that that's the
only way to do it and i don't know of
another way
um you know anarcho-capitalist friends
of mine tell me oh just get rid of all
government and just everyone will have
their own voice everyone's a citizen of
the globe and so on
you know you don't have to dig very far
into history to see what happens with
failed states i was just
i just read rachel kleinfeld's book a
savage order a savage order i had her on
my podcast and
you know she has a dozen examples in
this book of what happens when states
fail when the when the government the
central authority the police the
military when they're gone and it's not
good
you know yes new order does
spontaneously erupt from the bottom up
they're called gangs and mafia and they
impose order for sure but it's a savage
order it's an order that is accompanied
with violence and and
increased homicide rates and corruption
and there was a story in the early times
yesterday about
the
trial of el chapo going on now in new
york city and i had no idea almost
nobody did how many billions of dollars
this i mean don't think of this guy as a
drug lord or a thug or a thief or
something he's more like a captain of
industry
essentially in charge of a multi-billion
dollar international corporation yeah
that's really the way to think about it
but instead of investing in lawyers
and research and development teams and
things like this he's invested investing
in in assassins and bribery and and you
know he gave the president of mexico a
100 million dollar bribe you know how
much money uh he spent as having people
assassinated
okay so where there's not a free market
there's a black market and the black
market is is very ugly so you need some
regulation some law and order the people
most of people don't want to cheat they
don't want to assassinate they don't
want to bribe they want to be good
just like athletes don't want to dope
and use drugs most of them don't but the
moment somebody else you think somebody
else is then you kind of have to
and like in georgia's republic of
georgia rachel talks about this you know
is it's almost like if you're not in on
the corruption you're a sucker because
everybody's in on the corrupt system and
if you're trying to play by the rules
sucker you know and it's like okay we
don't want that yeah right so
the sea studying thing will be
interesting to see you know if this
develops what kind of law and order
they're going to have because you got to
have some
so you know to your point well you know
empowering people you got to have
you know property rights a banking
system a stable political economic
system you got to have people that are
running the
the regulation regulatory agencies that
are trustworthy trust is huge
yeah those were all really good points
and this is a huge part about designing
our future
now i want to talk on
the cognitive biases i want to talk
about the foundation of science there's
a lot that has been that we've been
struggling with in terms of it's really
difficult to do things like replicate
studies especially in really nuanced
biology or physics or wherever chemistry
and that makes it difficult to
understand if that
science
study on neuroscience can be replicated
then there's all of the then we have
what happened with peter james and helen
with you know with manipulating gender
and fat studies and still seeing those
be published right and then we
and then we also see this you speak a
lot about this the subjective
experiences that people claim that they
have had some sort of interaction with
some sort of of of the metaphysical
supernatural
experiences but that is a subjective
experience and that we need us to
scientifically figure out how to probe
that to replicate these so
we speak on that foundation of science
and how we're dealing with all of these
accidental
ways of corrupting it yeah well it's all
data it's all way of of kind of trying
to answer questions about the world
most of us think of science as you know
physicists or biologists or whatever but
as i said you know economists political
scientists so on they're running
experiments in the real world we can't
manipulate variables you can't have one
country be an autocracy for five years
and the one next to it be a democracy
and see what happens but that does
happen naturally like north and south
korea
uh is a is a prime example you can see
the difference from space
one's lit up and
in alive and active and they have a high
per capita gdp
they're four inches taller on average
than north koreans um they live i think
it's like 10 years longer
and all this is just gets down to diet
and money and just the basics of life
delivered by a democracy better than an
autocracy or dictatorship
so there again we just think of those as
experiments and
you know the the grievance studies
papers hoax you know i support that uh
as i did with pete's and james's
previous
uh the the the
the penis is a construct hoax uh the
conceptual penis is it's a concept uh
because it's it's a way of
sort of checking the checkers it's a
sort of an internal
regulatory system or method of
seeing if the people that are peer
reviewing are paying attention or if the
whole system is
such that you can't tell the difference
between a real and fake paper so at the
time that the conceptual penis paper
came out there was another one on the uh
feminist glaciology
that i was sure was a hoax i thought oh
and i wanted to comment on it i thought
oh boy i'm gonna this i'm going to be
made a fool of uh because it turns out
this was a fake so i actually called the
university university of oregon
uh for which the lead author was a
professor there and checked with their
pr department and they go no no this
this is real i'm like okay you know i
can't tell the difference
when that's the case then then there's a
there's a problem in the area but this
is just i think part of the kind of
normal checks and balances that go on in
science just like they do in democracy
although theirs was intentional fraud as
a hoax to make a point
uh work more subtle and worse is that is
is just when the whole
field is kind of gone off the rails and
there's nobody telling them you know
what we have no idea what you're talking
about this is insane go back to get back
onto the the path here so we have some
idea what you're doing
the problem is the academy is something
of a of a cloistered monks in the ivory
towers you know and they're they're
siloed off from
re you know the real world for the most
part in part that's it's institutional
and structural
in the sense that you know you go
through k through 12 undergraduate
graduate post-doc you get your
professorship you've never worked in the
real world to see
so you know i have academic friends you
know i don't know anybody that voted for
bush or trump it's like really because
half the country did
you know you know like 50 60 million
people voted for vote republican every
no matter who it is if you don't know
one
then you're in a bubble
so this is a problem you got to get out
get out a little more you know
go go out and mingle among the common
people
anyway so i think that that that's an
issue
and
and i want to hone in on this we are
we got to remove the hubris and we got
to admit that we are just human animals
that we have we're apes we're apes we
have to admit this because then we can
realize that we have biases then we can
realize that our pattern detection
systems have these biases speak to the
pattern detection malfunctions
yeah so the you know what's come out of
cognitive psychology in the last couple
decades
starting with the pioneering work of
taversky and kahneman
that you know we're not uh rational
calculators we're not homo economicists
we're not utility maximizers we're not
you know mr spock
we're not and um you know we're brains
are more like lawyers than than
scientists we just want to win the case
for our client our client in this case
is our beliefs and so you gather
evidence to support what you already
believe and you ignore the disconfirming
evidence confirmation bias or the
hindsight bias self-serving bias there's
a whole bunch of these now and
and
now there are training programs being
tested like how can we make people alert
to these cognitive biases so you give
students little tasks or
you know uh uh you know teaching tools
like here here's the top 10 cognitive
biases look out for them here and here
and here and here and they they learn to
do it they're pretty good
in other people
but then now there's one uh it's so it's
called the um what what is it the uh
no no it's the
oh i forget it's a bias bias it's
essentially i can't see it in myself but
i see it much better in your in other
people again you have to have other you
have to engage in other with other
people who you who don't agree with you
because they're the they're that's the
only way to find out if you know you do
have a bias you're not most of us can't
see it it's really hard to see it in
yourself
i mean when people say well what are
your biases if i knew i would do
something about it
i don't know i'm sure i have them
totally i mean i did kind of try to
force myself to read op-ed pieces that i
know i'm not going to like
you know some far left or somebody
politically or economically different
from me
uh just because i okay i'm just gonna
try to see if i can articulate their
argument so the steel mania i really
like this steel man as a counter to
straw manning it's really a great idea
it's hard to do
you know it
went by
in debate circles going back really
centuries or thousands of years you know
just can you articulate the other
person's position
in a debate
or like flip a calling you're going to
be pro-life or pro-choice you don't even
know you got to be come to the debate
prepared you know this kind of standard
college student debate techniques it was
one of the most important aspects of my
development was that debate
because you do have to immerse yourself
in the opposing perspective and steel
manning's so crucial in all our
discourse
you got to be able to sum up the other
person's perspective in great nuance and
detail where they say wow yeah you did a
good job summing up my point and then
you can break it down right or then you
can even build it up yeah
i think i could make a case for
creationism intelligent design
creationism pro-life
uh the holocaust denier you know because
i know those fee those areas pretty well
i can articulate their arguments i'm not
sure i could sell it
emotionally because i don't believe it
but i think i could articulate that's
hard to do for most of us
and extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence yes it's a great
phrase often attributed to carl sagan
was actually
coined by
a guy named marcelo trouzy who was a
sociologist of science that was one of
the co-founders of the
the first skeptic magazine called
skeptical inquirer for skeptical
magazine in america
um but basically it's it's
re-articulating hume's uh proportionate
principle proportionality you should
apportion your confidence in something
to the evidence
lots of evidence lots of confidence not
much evidence not much confidence
so carl's point you know extraordinary
claims aliens have landed that's an
extraordinary claim
you know uh you know something like it's
sunny in california to date that's not
an extraordinary claim don't need a lot
of evidence just look up uh but you know
aliens bigfoot whatever
that so you got to have a lot of
evidence for that and as we detect
patterns we have to be willing to admit
the misses not just the hits it's a
crucial part of science
i want to ask you about what do you
think are these most
important aspects of life to critically
think about how do we develop our
cognitive faculties for greater critical
thinking and teach children that
well i mean that's what we do at skeptic
in part we have junior skeptic for kids
middle school high school
i teach a course at chapman university
these are incoming freshmen they have to
take one of these
freshman foundations courses mind
skepticism 101 how to think like a
scientist that's the subtitle
what does that mean okay so i use all
the fun topics from skeptic like aliens
and conspiracy theories and bigfoot
ghosts atlantis you know there's
hundreds
and uh but but really if it's a way of
teaching how science works because if
atlantis isn't real or bigfoot isn't
real how do we know what is real what do
you believe
why do you believe the big bang or
theory of evolution but you don't accept
the creationist model why why not
you know it's not just because i'm
close-minded
or dogmatic no there are reasons well
what are those reasons okay let's go
through that so
anyway that's
and we should take that all the way down
to you know cha early childhood just
thinking about the world through fun
examples
that was you segued right into that next
point that i wanted to ask in in your 40
years now of professing you've how many
thousands of students now
and
skepticism 101 now in this course i want
to give us a synthesis what have been
some of these profound takeaways from
you from teaching
well again most people don't come into
it
thinking they don't know how to think
critically even critical thinking is is
kind of a clunky phrase
that sounds kind of pedantic
academic-ish
boring it's better than
you know in philosophy like a course in
logic
uh you know people's students eyes just
glaze over uh with some of those things
that which is why i think some of the
fun examples are current of current
events are a way to think about that
and um you know so sort of tap into
something they're interested in i have
my students they all have to do an
18-minute ted talk
so it sort of forces them to you know be
able to speak in front of an audience
that's hard to do but it's good
uh
and you know organize your thoughts
into around a single thesis just have a
point what's your point what are you
arguing have an opinion they also have
to write an opinion editorial for the
new york times the wall street journal
we don't submit them but you know it's
like as if they're going to do it and
there they have to you know in a brief
make their case you know
point point point point point conclusion
yeah okay and you know sometimes i have
to do debates you know so you have to
pick the other side and argue that case
yeah so anyway those are all just tools
i don't know if i know what i'm doing
any better than anybody else but you
know i think the more of us that do that
and that and the skeptical movement has
grown
just astronomically in the past 25 years
uh because there's
there's an interest in a market for
people really want to know what is the
explanation for fire walking for example
we had a firewalk right here yeah back
in the 90s yeah you can do it at tony
robbins unleashing power with that
that's right that's right the power of
the mind well no it's actually physics
but any case uh you know just just those
kind of demos and hands-on people want
to know
i'm very critical of the media they
think the general public is stupid and
has a short attention span not true
you know just again with these long-form
podcasts like what we're doing now or
joe rogan show for three hours people go
in depth and you know joe appeals to you
know mma fighter fans you know boxing
fans comedy fans science fans tech fans
everybody
and you know he's millions of people
watch his show for three hours two to
three hours unbelievable the
tv producers they're wrong they got it
wrong they think six minutes is the most
you can have
you need two or three people maybe four
or five screaming at each other oh
that's great television
this is terrible television those guys
are wrong and they're going to go out of
business if they don't
catch on to what's going on in podcasts
for example where you know the numbers
for some of them are bigger than they
are way bigger than say anderson cooper
on cnn
uh you know that's the reality don't
underestimate people's intelligence
which is why in part we got trump
because
you know the left made fun of the
flyover country the deplorables all
these ignorant
fundies and christians and they're all
stupid no no they're not there's and
they're certainly smart enough to know
when they're being made fun of
so trump in a way is a kind of a
you
pulling in the voting booth
and that's what we got so don't do that
and i would go as far as to say that it
may take several months of retraining
people into new careers as we talk about
automation and artificial intelligence
and the way that we are going to see a
lot of the existing job infrastructures
disappear new ones of course emerge but
it takes a period of multiple months if
not years to sometimes retrain people in
depth to become designers or engineers
etc
the question
off of that is
what would you recommend
the parents to teach the children
going into the automation age
right well that's the tension they had
now is how much time on a screen per day
you know some of the data on this
there's not a lot but there's some
research on this is summarized in uh
height and and lukianov's book coddling
of the american mind you know maybe
three two to three hours tops per day on
a screen
that can be used very effectively
because there's some great material
online
i i rarely watch like when i'm traveling
in a hotel i never turn the tv on
uh and not so much at home except for
just fun time with my my wife watching
some fun shows but most of the time the
content online is so much better than it
is on television so it's good but not
eight hours a day ten hours a day or six
hours of that's too much so you know
parents are trying to figure that out
psychologists are studying it now it
looks like two to three hours per day is
about max
and that's probably about right for
consuming educational material in any
case that you're going to absorb and
remember
um yeah and you know the whole
educational system you know kids in rows
with a instructor at the front with a
chalkboard you know that's that will
eventually i think disappear you know so
it's good to be
go to a brick-and-mortar place where
there's other kids your age i think
that's good
but but but the educational structure
can we need more experiments
agreed and
i want to touch on the
touch on god and this is a bit on
heavens on earth
um
the theory of evolution does not imply
that there is no god and i want to see
what you have to say about that because
god can be so many different definitions
for example what happened pre-big bang
so we if you do take an evolutionary
perspective with a god
one can potentially say that god is all
that is or that
god may be
infinity it may be divinity it may be
all of these consciousness it could be
all of these different things and that
everything is rooted with some sort of a
consciousness
yeah so part of my and we can
scientifically probe that we can totally
well we can certainly talk about it here
language makes a big difference
now it's been my privilege to meet a lot
of different people like uh richard
dawkins is a good friend deepak chopra
is a good friend jordan peterson is a
good friend now dawkins is an atheist as
am i you know deepak you know
deepak's no no no there is a god michael
there's a god now any christian would
look at deepak and read deepak this
guy's an atheist he doesn't believe in
god uh or you know jordan peterson you
know does he believe in god or not i
have no idea and i've tried to ask him
uh you know so a christian would
probably look at jordan go well i like
some of his values but he doesn't
mention jesus and god enough uh you know
he does he doesn't really believe in god
so it depends on what you mean by god
you know for deepak it's like the cosmic
consciousness you know consciousness is
the
i'll use his language you know it's the
it's the sort of fundamental principle
of the whole universe it's the ground of
all being you can't get underneath it
you drill down into atoms to sub-atomic
particles to quarks to strings and
there's consciousness no no no no no
it's all consciousness okay very
buddhist
so
part of the problem we have with in
science is you you need to define your
terms very carefully yes
and when you're talking about things
like well what was there before the big
bang
you can't even actually ask that
question it's a nonsensical question
because time began with the big bang
there is no before
before
it's like the analogy is what's north of
the north pole you get to the north pole
go further north i can't it's south in
every direction
okay so at some point we hit an
epistemological wall
i don't know and you don't either i saw
a bumper sticker militant agnostic i
don't know when you don't either you
know and it could be you know if the the
cosmologists will figure out some come
up with some model black holes are very
interesting black holes could give rise
to new universes the multiverse of its
various so we can probe and figure out
what potentially is pre-big bang yes
that's right yeah yeah now of course the
theaters can always say yeah but what's
before that
the the thing you you just postulated to
give the big bang where did that come
from
now of course they're going to say god
but then we should say well where did
god come from well god is that which
does not need an uh a causal explanation
how about the universe could be that
which does not need a causal explanation
here we're now just splitting hairs over
language
and you know we have certain limitations
cognitively based on the words we use or
the
the metaphors we use to try to grasp
something that's so difficult to grasp
like string theory in every documentary
they always show violins like that has
anything to do with strength theory it
doesn't but you know they're trying to
transport the literal meaning of
metaphors to transport from one place to
another
you know this this esoteric impossible
to understand idea of string theory into
my brain that understands violins but
not
that level of physics so
uh i think i think it's you know it's
good to keep an open mind but
again like with the
the afterlife
i don't know and i i i'm willing to be
pleasantly surprised if you know when i
close my eyes here for the last time i
wake up and there's carl sagan stephen j
gould and there's my friends my parents
you know okay you know assuming it's not
like as hitch described it to celestial
north korea you know we have this
dictator that knows everything and
controls everything you do that that
doesn't sound heavenly to me but if it
was something nice i guess yeah totally
open to it but that's different from
it's probably true i can't say that
i mean if anything it looks like it's
probably not true but
willing to be surprised
and we are i think building out the
tools that we can better hypothesize on
these scenarios i think and another one
is the what happens after death what
happens before birth these are really
interesting questions to explore where
is the seed of consciousness originate
what would you how would you answer that
well i don't have a great explanation
for consciousness more than anybody else
does because nobody does but
in terms of the hard problem of how how
you get
neuron swapping chemicals it's just
chemistry it's
uh into doing the kind of thing we can
do this kind of feeling like there's
something floating
off of that
mechanical physical system that is not
physical
you know in a platonic kind of way like
what do you what is beauty and truth in
a triangle or a perfect circle
where is that there is no perfect circle
in the physical world it's it's an idea
okay there's no material in the idea
how do ideas actually come into contact
with and and
with the mechanical system to tweak it
this is deepak's point you know i think
a certain thought it caused my blood
pressure to go up how does that happen
this is just a thought
according to the materialist it's just
neuron swapping chemicals you know well
to me it's a feedback system and your
blood pressure goes up or whatever but
any case i i don't have a good
explanation i think
it's got to be bottom-up it's going to
be neurons firing it's going to be a
complex adaptive system that emerges out
of a simpler system like like economies
do something like that
it's a hard problem
best argument for cryonics is i'd like
to be frozen and come back 500 years to
see how all these things turn out
oh
consciousness we figured that out the
22nd century no problem here it is oh
that was it
yeah
that's one of the benefits of the
exponential technology ages being able
to potentially have the generation
that's born today be the ones that
medical technology outpaces there
well yeah the
takeoff point where the average lifespan
increases
uh more than one one year for every year
and then you get to live forever
not i don't buy that argument completely
i i hope it's true but it's like
retaining youthful homeostatic capacity
your whole life so you feel like a 16
year old your whole life 16 yen and
maybe 25 would be better yeah more
involved yeah yeah yeah something like
that
uh
yeah i you know i
when i listen to people like ray
kurzweil read his books and so on it's
very hopeful i like i like the big
thinking the inspirational but often
feels like religion to me i often feel
like i'm back in church
we are the chosen people we are the ones
that get to live forever
are you sure because you know they
always said that and they're always
wrong so you know maybe
but to what to that point i say look
okay
don't you want to live 500 years okay
look just get me to 90 like without
prostate cancer get me to 100 without
alzheimer's
and senility you know and then we'll
talk
okay so in other words protopia solve
little problems one at a time so that
you live longer at a higher quality of
life even if we all hit the wall at 120
or whatever it's over
at least more of us made it in that
upper
window there
of a quality life okay that's pretty
good if we could do that
and as you talk to other people about
god and all these other nuanced
concepts that we aim to have discourse
on to build a better world you you make
this really interesting point that we
must retain an extremely high level of
skepticism as we look at our especially
social feeds with bots and and deep
fakes we retain a really high level of
skepticism but at the same time we need
to retain a high level of openness to
new ideas
evidence for these new ideas this
balance is super important
yeah carl sagan called it the burden of
skepticism a lecture he gave here in
pasadena that i went to in 1988 that
inspired me to start the magazine and
become a professional skeptic as it were
that is you have to be open-minded
enough to recognize and accept radical
new ideas but not so open-minded that
your brains fall out you believe every
crazy thing that comes along
it's hard to find that that balance it
depends on the field the area the
evidence and so on everyone is different
but that that's what we want to aim for
yeah
so i want to now couple last questions
on the way out we're
hockey sticking in terms of population
we're hockey sticking in terms of
exponential technology we've really
haven't been at this type of a point in
civilization before
what are your thoughts on this
inflection point that we're at well
population wise i'm not terribly worried
because if you follow the curve
out it it it said a plateau it
stabilizes stabilized around 2050 at
about nine nine ten billion yeah yeah
and so i at the end of the moral arc i
sort of carried out some calculations
just taking the conservative u u.n
projections you know by 2100 we'll be
kind of back close to where we are now
with much better technology and
distribution of food
such that everybody will have plenty to
eat
and then because of social effects of
like empowering women and educating
women and birth control technologies
family size just naturally goes down
you know it's already below replacement
level 2.1
children per parent on average is
replacement level and many many
countries dozens of western countries
are below that yeah okay so they're
going to face a birth dearth
much you know the overpopulation problem
is i think has already been solved
just have to just just just carry it out
and out of these 7.7 billion humans that
currently are here and we're gonna ramp
up to nine and ten billion
are we ready for transhumanism have we
evolved morally and ethically for uh i
think we're on the verge i think we can
get there uh think of these extra couple
billion people as brains thinking about
how to solve problems more people
working on a problem more creativity
more creativity this is good for people
to buy my books whatever
no but i mean this was julian simon's
point in his debates with uh paul
ehrlich is that you know ehrlich thinks
of people like cattle or animals that
have to be dispensed with and get rid of
and eliminated and reduced
like like their disease contagions
rats over running the system you know i
mean it's a very
unhumanistic way of looking at people
whereas julian simon you know he was
like this you know billions more people
thinking and producing and working and
living a
full life this is really good
and i'm more on the julian simon side
and really he's won most of those bets
well all the bets i mean ehrlich has
been wrong about pretty much everything
and yet he's still pounding the drum for
overpopulation well go to africa and
work on it there because
but really there's no there's no magic
to it again if you empower women you
know give them freedom economic
empowerment they make family size
decisions about reproduction and
children
and the birth control technologies
available and cheap
it just takes care of itself
okay
michael what would you say is a core
driving principle of yours
well i want to know what's true
with the small t
um and you know i don't like
obfuscation and and and you
know i'm just trying to trying to
understand the world myself
uh and
make a little bit of a difference in
terms of like
pushing the moral arc just a little bit
up this idea of protopia i'm not a
utopian thinker i'm never gonna run for
president or or you know i'm never gonna
be you know a world-changing
uh figure like that but but that's not
work where real change happens anyway it
happens from all of us just kind of
regular folks doing our thing in a way
that makes the world slightly better
today than it was yesterday slightly
better tomorrow than it is today
just incremental change all of us can
that that's where the real change comes
from
yeah
i love that
and each one of us embodying that is how
we can build a better future i love that
if you could rebuild civilization from
scratch how would you design it well i'm
kind of thinking about that because we
go to mars that's kind of what we're
going to do i think
the experiments we ran here are pretty
good
you know the constitution declaration
independence constitution bill of rights
and i've been rereading the the
federalist papers you know
madison hamilton and
um all these franklin all these guys
were thinking this very question here we
go we have an opportunity what do we do
you know how much power do we give the
state governments versus the federal
government and what about a military
what about police what about
the economic system with trade what
about banking do we need a central bank
you know these are all super hard
questions and there is no single answer
to be found there's just you know just
better or worse on a scale
of solutions to problems that work or
don't work
as measured by
you know just human prosperity health
longevity
you know it sounds crude to say we want
people to make more money but money
buys you things
if nothing else time and security
plus of course food and travel and
things like that
you know so you got to get that right um
john adams famously said i have to study
the science of politics so my children
can study the science of whatever you
know the different fields that he listed
so that their children can study poetry
and music and art
i think naval architecture was one of
the ones he said so that their children
can study architecture you know like the
greek pillars or whatever and i think
that's right if we don't get it right
you know nothing else will survive
you know science art music this is all
wonderful but if you don't get the
political system right you don't get
those
so
you know i'm i'm more interested in
biology and psychology and so on less
interested in economics and politics but
i study it because i feel like i really
i need to understand that because it
kind of precedes all these others we're
not going to get to do those if we don't
have the right political economic system
i highly recommend others to dive deep
into the constitution the federalist
papers the bill of rights etc this is
a good way to understand the foundation
of what we have
here that so many
even just diving deep into history into
big history and just looking back
thousands of years and just trying to
look into the eyes of the humans that
helped build the houses hospitals
schools governments the resource flows
that enabled other people to have
increased baselines of food and water
just really doing that process can be so
humbling and so important
last last two here
are we in a simulation
no i don't think so
now i've read that i've read the
arguments and the bayesian
probability arguments which i think are
problematic because we just we have no
numbers to reliable numbers to plug in
there you know i mean it's not
impossible but it's just so unlikely it
doesn't really pass the you know reality
check
you know i don't see any like buffering
signs or you know pixelated uh skies or
whatever so i think probably not
all right but you are in
in favor of the universe being math
and well
yeah i know i know max
tag mark and i read his book
and some of that to me it's sliding over
into kind of metaphysics
and i'm a little out of my league there
what do you mean that the universe is
mathematical it's like when there's a
scene in this documentary about ray
kurzweil he's at the ocean he's watching
the waves
and the producers what are you thinking
about
uh i think it was it was like a
computation
you know the the molecules in the water
those are computational molecules like
what is he talking about what the hell
are you talking about anyway i to me
this is a little it's fun and
interesting
i'm not sure what to what the take away
is from that
so what if it's mathematical okay
and now what
does it produce
testable hypotheses that we can decide
this is a better model than that one to
explain the cosmos or whatever it is
you're you're trying to explain and i
think max does say it's kind of
speculative and i know
math mathematicians and physicists that
don't agree with them
and okay let them
hash that out because i'm really way out
of my league there i think an easy way
maybe to help people
with this thought experiment is to run
our own simulation once we have the
adequate computing power and code to
press play on the big bang and fast
forward 13.8 billion years until this
exact moment where we're sitting here
having this conversation we see that and
we go whoa
maybe
often you know when i when i watch star
trek with the you know the holodeck and
you know the virtual reality is so real
you can't distinguish between real
reality and the holodeck virtual reality
but they're always doing fun things like
shakespeare or
or no no they do um
what's his name uh sherlock holmes or
wharf is doing battle games or whatever
my fear is that it would all just evolve
into a basically a porn movie that
everybody's just having sex all day long
in this virtual reality and that's it
civilization basically comes to an end
because we're apes right i mean the
number one most watched videos ever
anywhere is there's pornography
it's just staggering yeah you know it's
like oh really this is what it's come
down to 21st century
our civilization
pornography come on
is is our next evolution to make
artificial general intelligence
well again
these big questions is it going to be a
threat to us
let's just solve specific problems like
how can i get my tesla to self-drive
better than it is now
you know in the next upgrade that elon
sends out it's slightly better than it
was this upgrade that's it let's just
keep going in that direction
you know we get to the point where i i
punch the thing i go navigate lax
and it drives up on the sidewalk because
there's traffic and it mows down
pedestrians you know this is one of
these scenarios how many times do you
think that's going to happen before
federal regulators come in and go elon
your company is over we're taking over
you can't do this you know whatever they
would do because regulators do that i'm
not worried about those kinds of things
it almost though gives us a sense of
letting go and surrendering to the fact
that our next evolution is to make this
artificial general intelligence and that
may
feel a little more at ease potentially
paker makes a point that
it's sort of self-refuting these
arguments that
you're saying we're going to make a
computer so smart that it can cure
cancer but it has no idea it's so dumb
that it just kills everybody in the
process of curing cancer
really i mean you can't i mean it
doesn't even make sense
there's uh there's more nuance okay well
the last question is michael what do you
think is the most beautiful thing in the
world
well my wife and my son and my daughter
and my family
uh beyond just you know the personal
thing i i would say what gets me up in
the morning every day
is just how lucky we are to be alive i
mean the chances that you and i were
even born is astronomically low and that
we get to live in a country where it's
relatively safe i get to eat every day
and and so to me that's the most
beautiful thing it's just life
it is such a blessing that we're here
totally and living we could have been
born cows in india or something maybe
that wouldn't be so bad cows in texas
that would be bad
part of me does feel like there's a
bigger experiment happening on earth
than we may realize and on other rocks
orbiting stars around the universe maybe
that would be interesting and then we
play through these flesh vehicles the
game
well this was sagan's argument for
searching for
the seti program searching for
extraterrestrial intelligence if they're
there it means somebody else
made it
through this kind of stage we're in
protect you know rapid accelerating
technological development with our eight
brains
uh somehow they got there and did it
without nuking themselves global warming
their planet whatever
uh that that i have to agree that would
be that would be good
this has been such a pleasure are you up
honor thank you thank you for coming on
to the show really good again another
example of you know in depth deep dive
into important topics that people like
to think about yeah absolutely and
everyone huge thank you for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we would love for
you to comment below with your thoughts
on some of the things we talked about
let's get the community chatting go and
talk to other people about what we
chatted about
also check out michael's links below in
the bio as well
and
we
are really appreciative of your support
enabling us to do cool things like come
out to los angeles and talk to great
minds like michael
join us below as well and
go and build the future everyone go and
manifest your destiny into the world
build the future we love you so much and
we will see you soon
peace
very good that's it great